[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to a very
special LIVE top 5 sky mod of the week
now wait a minute this is technically
where we destroy the magic that is sure
yeah yeah we're gonna start off this
evening with the very first ever
Kevin van quiz the Kevin bank will so to
be clear a lot of what we do is lies in
the sense that I actually install and
test the mods and then cam sells them
back to me but in this case I genuinely
haven't got a clue what he's written are
you ready for the first question okay
here we go
okay true or false Kevin van Lord is the
most dangerous man in Skyrim okay close
correct Japanese no man
Kevin is no mere man false dawn and yeah
more of a God than anything else
true or false Kevin wears armor because
he likes how it feels against this skin
why he doesn't feel anything well
there's a follow-up to the false
he doesn't have skinnier scales so yeah
that's true
true or false Kevin is actually
cold-blooded yeah false very very good
Kevin is largely a mechanical being he
doesn't have a lot of blood what blood
there is is mostly oil true or false
Kevin killed the alien queen and got
wasted drinking her acid blood
this is yours this is actually true yeah
yeah acid is the only thing that can get
Kevin properly drunk yeah yeah yeah he
got fully crunk on that don't try that
yourselves is why we did get Kevin drunk
once didn't we yeah on acid was that not
like the colloquial term for an illegal
drug I mean is in alien blood
Kevin's secretly dreams of a world where
he and chicken kine can coexist yeah
that's definitely false this is false on
every level a Kevin has my secrets B
he's never dreamt in his life one day
Kevin van Lord will destroy us all
that's true that's true yesterday enjoy
enjoy your evening guys well you can I
[Applause]
know some of you have come from like
other countries to be here it's silly
which what's why are you here hi it's
amazing it whales definitely I
definitely catch the strange places far
away they come I guess we were trying to
figure out who who came from the
furthest and I think Jared might be in
the lead Jared where did you go bro did
you come from
he made from America whereabouts in
America whereabouts
Connecticut Connecticut I have no idea
where Connecticut is New England huh
it's in America anywhere further than
America Canada amazing you realize
that's not actually the whole of Canada
all right sev Seth time for Maude number
one that's time for modern umber one
well I say it's time I mean
we've actually got a special guest more
today it's doable bear bear he's doing
the same thing you did last time where
he's just like you know what I just I
had better things no I think he's gonna
come with come on power
yeah is the first one that you've got
lista cam is true elk of Skyrim yes ma
number one this week is true elk of
Skyrim yo any of you guys remember a
handsome elk majestic even by the name
of P van Nordal yeah yeah okay okay well
apparently fee ban normal is a model now
so we're gonna go find the true elk of
sky yeah let's have we don't even she's
don't mean has seen Kevin here today
there he is he's angry Garcia's cause
he's furious oh here we go
cultists goat over there go on she wait
say cap up goat over there
wait Doberman fine nibble for your
master we've still got the weird jumping
model it's okay dunno what happened
Kevin's blades are so sharp he doesn't
actually need to touch the flag so he's
all tuckered out from a murder
oh it's alright you have done your cell
again over snack and we still haven't
found an elk there no that's for that's
where we're going but there's keltus go
to my way you saw he's defending
back who's gonna get cheese bun go on
well with overbear behind us you could
say he maybe need some come on bear oh
yes very good very good
don't encourage him wait wait wait what
is that what is that oh shoot I think
it's cheese well did you get it
Paolo give chase come back wait your new
master demands you wait what do you make
of their annual well the backside is
incredible I guess I do say that a lot
what differences are we looking for here
well okay so in the more diffuse brain
up the page like you would see that M
the previous elk in Skyrim were like an
amalgamation of an elk and deer and a
moose moose thank you sir the first
place this Bruce moose and then so this
is actually what an elk should look like
and there's also separate moose I think
now is Skyrim as well well the good news
is I have no internet so I'm gonna just
that's right I just don't get a guess
what the mods about look at the new
horns yeah yeah those said antlers up
horns shut up Jesus to become cheese he
is about to become no dummy Robinson god
damnit so I think the thing I'm seeing
the most right in the on the out mod is
that they're now two-toned so the the
neck yeah is is dark and the body is
light which I'm pretty sure wasn't there
before yeah I think you're right alright
it is also apparently the mod creators
first-ever mod so right on he obviously
likes hell yeah good she
okay next next monitor okay is essential
player by strategy master essential
player oh this is a good one
it's quite clever this is actually gonna
require ten god mode off yes yeah so
cept you want to explain what this mod
is then so essential player changes up
the way that you would play an RPG like
Skyrim
whereas in vanilla Skyrim when you die
you die game over you go back to your
last save or autosave what this wants to
do is reintroduce the the old RPG method
of if you die you become fatigues and
you have a moment to sort of get back up
and if you don't then you die if you do
die you then become a ghost and then you
can return to your course and go and
find all of your loops and then get it
back so this guy is going to take Kevin
down and observe look at Oh as he
struggles
alright so Kevin is now in struggle mode
which you can now fight for your life
right yeah well you can no no you stay
down from it for a few seconds and you
back up with minimal health and you go
down again you go down again yes okay
you're in your pants you die and you
become a ghost and well done dovabear he
avenged them okay so we're just an
ethereal sort of flow jetting what is I
know we might be like one of those sort
of like see-through versions of
ourselves we are a bit though because if
we come back to our corpse alright what
a handsome corpse and you try and
interact with it in a minute it should
we should ceased being this weird
corporeal be able come back I'm sure
because there's guarding our corpse look
at that it guarding oh I really hope
he's guarding run let's lead to our own
corpse take everything so we just looted
their own corpse this mod allows your
player to become a theory like all other
unkillable NPCs when you lose all health
you will kneel on the ground like we saw
and stand back up with a small amount of
remaining health I actually think I
prefer this way I know it's a lot
breaking I prefer each time you become
unconscious you will sustain an injury a
number of penalties to health manage for
Magica fatigue regenerates etc injuries
will recover naturally as it ghosts you
become invulnerable invisible walk
silently cannot attack and cannot
interact with the environment and then
it takes 30 seconds for what we saw his
body to regenerate as it were that's the
whole mod yeah I guess it kinda just
takes you out of combat for a minute but
it doesn't require you to reload that's
all its really doing is skipping that's
probably the most irritating reload yeah
I mean it probably I guess it kind of
makes it a bit easier Wow
I tried to punch it in he's shouting
it's alright skeevers over that mountain
now he's okay there look he's all right
fine
that's cuz he's still flying he hasn't
landed yet okay thanks mark alright I'm
really want to see this one this is so
good alright so what this is is called
dragon fire technically enhanced rest
shouts oh yeah what it does basically
just show what it does there you go
alright so basically what it's doing is
it's trying to make the shout the
especially the elemental shouts
more like how the dragon shout so they
look very similar but just one is blue
so just do just do the first word okay
okay then ready then see if you can try
and do two words you think it thing can
get this elk I definitely believe you
get yellow
that 300 I got him though well but he's
funny away
he's funny going away no I think you
fell over for completely different
reasons
look at the size of those that they're
frozen
yeah oh wow I don't know you know now we
get a chance to really take in the elk
yeah look at the quality at out you
leave him alone Dover there don't you
don't you we're studying he'll already
eaten all right
he's pretty mad he's pretty mad as hell
oh it's still absorbing dragon subtle
and you can see their prosperity like
that look at this going for that show
alright so team out okay guys this is
what the new drag this is what the new
fire breath looks like as you can see I
think it looks better wow that's a lot
of fire it's actually that's actually
very reminiscent to the way Kevin
hatched so where most dissociate their
way out he just shouted y'all and the
whole thing just like atomized around
him I've got the perfect answer to this
do you know what animal is the only
animal that's really capable of bringing
down a jack a dragon oh yeah
he's down there completely engulfed in
flames
I don't know is he snacking I get up
that's a powerful go that's a route to
powerful powerful I think is that it did
we kill them all
Hey
well done Kevin man cooked the good
thing it was strong and POW every day
for breakfast all right so I feel like
this one's gave me a bit more of a
return to our old form this one is the
vagabond swordsman so do you want it
this is gonna be weird but do you want
to drive
can i but this board gives us like new
armor and a weapon as well they said if
you want to craft craft the armor you
need to go to leather leather okay yeah
go go to leather and in leather you
should find everything you need
well except for the fact that we have no
Oh leather
well let's let's console command in some
leather hey hey that works alright we've
got it
swordsman gloves dark version so the
thing this mod is like a variation a
reskin of what looks like the Thieves
Guild armor and a few others yeah it's
got that vibe to certainly
which is there a sword yeah oh go to
Daedric Daedric Daedric for the sword
it's not particularly high res granted
no but so what's this meant to be way
away wherever zoom in on the oh god I'm
forgetting our sword to make mature
there's the cross guard yeah yeah that's
the hill what's the little spiky bits
all the way though I don't know guys
what are they for
what easy what are these spiky bits for
what's a break at the blade catcher
blade catcher all right fair enough
fairly cool town so what's this meant to
me is this made me like a thieves yeah
or a bit more like the but what does
vagabond paper Hannon Cameron it just uh
a narrative world so that was the sword
then we've got all the salve cruel yeah
is it just inside what is bigger
basically it's classed as a battle ax
yes but it is still technically a sir I
think we need to remove some heads of
this sword you know I've actually
realized ham is that weak because we use
battle axes so rarely in the game yeah
so we we don't really see the
the kill moves the battle-axes yet often
that was given okay we don't happen to
be dead
so very very they're an act at once
which is why it got so loud all of a
sudden yeah there we go come on take
some heads
decapitation please oh there we go
okay Oh another one Oh No yes so it's
like guy you kind of want to tell them
like look whatever you do just don't
don't bend over sorry Lydia
whoopsie-daisy
we just don't give him money because
we're the main factor in Lydia's
insurance policy it is a great regret
that I have to inform you of Lydia's
death okay so we might a lot of today
you can do it you can do it right here
in Riverwood okay the final earth day
guys it's called fish road or you know
how that thing in Skyrim when you're
walking around and you come across a
door and it's locked and you have any
lock picks or it's master and you can't
be bothered and you just think I'm the
dragon board I should be able to the
shimmy it open and you don't allegedly
peace with my words can move dragons why
can't I open this door
now you can okay guys it's another slow
it's a novice lock novice easy but yeah
look oh wait a lockpick oh jesus what a
pain in the ass except hey
and in we go let's go on let's go into
kappa tater but not just Dora said y'all
just not there's more but wait some but
wait okay so we need to find some Chet
locked chest alright
that's not expert chess oh shut it it
shouted it Saturday
we go there Oh whoopsie daisies this is
somewhat this guy there we go he's
unlocked he's open everyone you can't
unlock people what are you doing I'm
making a load of miniature chickens how
scared this give work seven lets get
work that chickens not big enough Sam oh
[Music]
you heard it oh you get exploded oh no
no now we go to the copter it means
gonna say whoopsie daisies that's
amazing
you can only maybe chickens so big and
then they explode for this is what we
all wanted to see you know what I
thought you know my favorite part about
that is cam it's the little chickies
riding well it's that if you go go back
to where you were before go back to
where you were
I like that what it kind of looked like
it looks like a family photo
cuz the chickens doing this that's the
chicken pose that that is the chicken
version of blue-steel it's like yeah
what happened what's going on all right
here we go all right let's fly well I
don't know what happened
but we didn't go very far I don't know
what you did but we're too big too big
to fly let's make ourselves the size of
a chicken I feel like the more
appropriate music would be the Jurassic
Park theme you're like a tiny goofy
height he's in the lone grass well these
chickens are giant this is like Jurassic
Park he checks it like him they do move
in her again Oh punch him in the foot
all right chicken how about you
[Applause]
tiny Kevin oh he's like a little Kevin
Van Horn or an action figure he did so
well oh oh it's okay
he's okay the leaves slayed him
oh is that we played the hell was that
San Luis that can we create disaster
sample was that I don't know but he's
landing I'm I'm scared
graceful graceful as ever
wait wait wait wait a minute where in
the hell are we like how far did we
before did we go oh I mean we did wait
we flew from here today uh I think guys
you just witnessed Kevin's largest
flight yeah you also got the sneak
preview of Kevin's latest character it's
Kevin the stick insect that was horrible
that was really awful that was like that
was how they're like a geiger vibe to it
yeah it was really weird
coming here it for Kevin Bernard
I mean and it's beautiful amber eyes I
mean both both seven I know that you're
not you're not really here today
yesterday you're here to see this guy
and that's well I'm here to swap Kevin
acknowledges the applause he's not
feeling a thing so anything all right
like a constant drone got a question
throw a hand up in the air and Mark do
you want to dive in like we're gonna
like answer all yeah let's go did
someone have not heard from you well
Marty that's the microphone so mr. dick
how are you two feeling after your first
live show
I'm feeling really flushed yeah like
kidneys kidneys war I feel like my
cheeks are like a beetroot color I think
you definitely need more beer now that
you've had time to recover from
counseling Johnny I'm falling over flora
are we gonna finally get fall in love
with Zelda uh who I've actually thought
about that quite a few times except it
would because falling in love with Lara
had all those lovely ELLs I figured we
should call it falling in love with link
if you guys could have any mod in real
life apart from cheese because obviously
would it be modern real life probably
dovabear I mean I have a few enemies and
I think if I had a giant bear that's
right I would have less enemies so yeah
joy bear that's really hard um dovabear
stop confusing me okay um I'm a month
okay did you guys living chickens it
would probably be exploiting South
London was decimated so many chicken
shops sweet roll say open the box
they're real sweet rolls so um live
tasting that's it wherever it is this
gonna kill me okay
cheers Cheers Sam the first sweet roll
can confirm delicious amazing so what I
know someone might steal your sweet
rolls but so I think in the name of
being more friendly should I leave them
out so people can steal my sweet roll
the skyrim logo and of course the the
first one let me guess someone stole
your sweet roll so I'm we should have
passed them around or something I don't
know we'll figure it out after we know
they've got to be stolen thank you a
given I just don't people to trip over
the camera when they try to steal them
which is gonna be a thing that happens
wait Steph those guys are stealing your
spirits can we please have a big round
of applause for the make of the sweet
rolls Chrissy how did you get involved
in top 5 scary months of the week
excellent question
all right so their origins of top 5
scaring modes of the week the first
people to ever really do the show at as
being cool I saw that being called
tougher scary motorWeek was actually two
of our us colleagues called John Davison
and Sean McKenna's but yeah the idea for
scary months actually came from myself
and Jane Douglas wasn't called top 5
scary modes it was just about it was
here are some mods that are that you can
now do in Skyrim it was the day that
modeling became available on the Steam
Workshop yeah cuz I remember she
downloaded the mod tools' and was trying
to actually make a mod at first I know
like no Jane I just saw just stop now
make like you don't know what you're
doing my little brother couldn't come
today cause he's only 16 texted me and
asked if you guys could do more silly
mods yeah I mean I know we're a very
serious show yeah
but I think we could do some more yeah
that's gonna be real tough for us
actually that the main way that we end
up doing this show is that we we get a
list of silly mods and we go
that's to suffice to say and then we
just sell oh reel it back in we go like
we've got to do one law friendly mod
otherwise we also get mad we also have
one policy on the show as we will never
do any of the really dumb like nude mods
we don't do those and that's not gonna
change
yeah thank you guys for you know the
show everything that you guys do I love
reality check is always brilliant thanks
man you're the best I like this guy I
like this guy reality what and there was
some dumb science to it I keep trying to
convince him to do a new show called
Realty check which is all about it's all
about like property prices in London but
how much would this how much would this
house cost in real life yeah yeah anyway
what's the question I just want to ask
so you guys play sky him all the time
for the show yeah how often do you
actually face crime in your spare time
that is good at the moment
and over the last year not that much but
on my own I have accumulated like at
least 600 hours on my own in this game
my save at home on the Xbox 360 is at
150 hours but on this one it's 708 708
and that's just on this account yeah and
we played through on the show another
accounts who would you most like to have
as a special guest on the show oh um I
would like gopher yeah go for a be great
yeah
so he's um he's another Skyrim motor he
did really great videos I also like Peru
chill right I just want to speak to him
because his voice is Wonder right did
actually making this mold and did this
show keep you happy doesn't life am i
happy in life did this show make you
make your life more happier than before
am i am i drowning right now question um
well Kent Chuck Norris is actually based
on Kevin from the word yeah even though
he's a human being
so yeah in that sense I'm the other
quote what happened was was Kevin Kevin
shaved one time and most of the the
sword crumbled but a single hair fell
and where it landed in the soil it grew
into a tree and that tree pers produced
one fruit and that fruit was Chuck
Norris okay so now wait a minute
no so here's the issue yeah here's the
issue
the issue with that is the Imperials are
jerks right I mean clearly they say if
they season but then but then the
Stormcloaks are a racist yeah like
they're really racist
alright so the way so I can the easiest
way to break it down right is that the
the Imperials are david cameron okay and
then the store and the Stormcloaks are
you kid yeah pretty much
and nobody wants to nobody wants to
support you kids so guys thanks for
coming down it looks a bit like a fist
to fist but i feel like a fist covered
in blood your blood for actually saying
you know even a piece of paper documents
are sealed in wax and pressed
yeah you just punch he just presses them
if they were to make
bust movie and/or series who would play
a good question I'm assuming that the
mean samurai right we're not allowed
okay guys have you do any of you guys
watch Game of Thrones the mountain the
new one you walk in mouth when you make
the strongest man in Iceland or
something it's our plan to petition a
professor to include kevin van nord in
the elder scrolls 6 as an npc yeah so a
time will come your time will come when
we are gonna love me like we've never
lobbied before yeah if only they know we
count on you guys to lobby with us okay
okay if you want to come and drink with
us we'd love to drink with you yeah and
also will be available for the promised
hugs yeah and for the hugs as well give
us give us 30 minutes to pack this all
down but thank you very much for your
coming
and a thanks to Kevin as well thank you
Kevin thank you Kevin thank you Kevin
thank you
[Music]
you